everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem balanced binary tree
we're given a binary tree and we want to
determine if it is height balanced what
exactly do they mean by height balanced
well it's defined by saying that for
every single node in the tree if we take
the left and right subtrees of this node
the heights of these left and right sub
trees will differ by at most one so in
here you can see taking a look at the
root node uh it has a left sub tree
what's the height of this left sub tree
let's call it one right because there's
one node in the left sub tree what about
the right subtree how m what's the
height of this right sub tree well it's
two right we can determine that just by
looking at it so then the left sub tree
has a height of one the right subtree
has a height of two the difference is uh
at most one right because if we take the
absolute value of the difference we get
one so we'll say the
difference is one so we just did that
for the root node but we have to do that
for every single node to make sure that
the left and right subtrees of every
single node differ by at most one and
just to show you a counter example so
this is kind of a badly drawn tree but
take a look at the root node right if we
take a look at the left tree over here
the height is three if we take a look at
the right subtree the height is three so
the difference is zero which fits into
our criteria so from the root node the
left sub tree and the right subtree are
balanced but if we take a look at let's
say this node right we take a look at
its left sub tree which is empty right
so that's has a height of zero the right
subtree has a height of two so in that
case the difference is two minus zero
which is two right positive two which is
greater than one so just because uh from
here taking a look at the root note the
left and right sub trees are balanced
doesn't mean that that's going to be
true for every single node because we
just looked at this node the left and
right subtrees were not balanced how can
we solve this efficiently let me first
show you kind of a naive approach and
then we'll see how we can actually
optimize that so if we were asking
naively right the first question we're
asking is from the root node are the
left and right sub trees balanced how do
we even determine that well do you agree
that we could probably do a recursive
dfs on the left sub tree to determine
the height of the left subtree do a
recursive dfs on the right subtree to
determine the height of this subtree and
then we could compare those and make
sure that the difference is less than or
equal to one do you agree that we could
do that probably right i'll explain more
details in the code but for now let's
just assume we can do that we start from
the root we run a dfs on the left and on
the right that means we go through every
single node in the tree so we just did
an o of n operation right and we were
able to determine okay from the root
node yes it is balanced but we're not
done yet right we now we have to
continue to ask that question for every
single node right so the next question
we're going to ask is suppose on the
left subtree right from the left subtree
are the left and right subtrees from
this node also balanced and of course
they're both zero so we determine that
they are and then we'll have to
recursively go to the right subtree from
here we're going to ask are the left and
right subtrees balanced yes they are but
we'll recursively have to continue we'll
have to do that from this node and then
we'll have to do that from this node
since we're running a recursive dfs on
every single subtree on this uh root
tree we're going to have to do it
basically an o of n operation each time
we ask that question is it balanced from
here is it balanced from here is it
balanced from here and we could have a
really big tree and we'd have to do an
oven operation each time of n is the
number of nodes in the tree and if we
have to do this n operation n times
we're going to get a time complexity of
o of n squared so now the question is
can we do better than that is there any
repeated work and i'll show you that yes
there is repeated work and it basically
can be eliminated by
asking the question in a different order
what i mean by that is instead of first
asking if the entire tree is balanced
from the root node right that's the
first question we ask is it balance
starting from here instead of asking
that we uh
do this bottom up we start we
recursively instead of asking it from
here we're going to check okay is this
entire right subtree balanced before we
do that we're going to ask is this
entire subtree balance and we're going
to keep going lower and lower until we
get to the base case once we get to the
base case then we're going to go back up
and i'll show you how that's actually
going to end up eliminating the repeated
work if we do it in this order we'll
only have to visit each node at most one
time which will ensure the overall time
complexity is going to be big o of n
rather than n squared okay so when we
get to the root before we check if it's
balanced from here we're going to check
if it's bounced from this right subtree
that makes sense so far and then before
we ask from this position we're gonna
ask is it bounced from this leaf node
right and now we can't really go any
lower because this node doesn't actually
have any children so of course its
subtrees are going to be balanced but
now we're good right we we determine
okay this
from this node yes the left and right
subtrees are balanced right and then we
pop back up suppose and then uh we we
also want to make sure that this node is
also balanced it's the same thing right
the left and right childs don't exist so
yeah it's balanced from here as well so
we determined that right now we know
from at least these two nodes yes the
left and right sub trees are balanced
from these two nodes okay now we want to
know is it balanced from this node how
can we determine that aren't we going to
have to go back down and revisit the
entire right subtree in the entire left
sub tree again no and i'll show you why
as we are determining if this subtree is
balanced let's also at the same time
simultaneously let's make sure we get
the height of this tree the entire
height of this subtree and let's do the
exact same thing for this node make sure
we get the entire height of this subtree
because once we've done that then once
we go back up to the parent node from
here it will be easy we already have the
height of this tree we already have the
height of this tree we can take the
difference between those make sure it's
less than or equal to one and then we're
good we we didn't even have to revisit
these trees right from this node now
we've already determined yes it's also
balanced from this position right so now
we've determined it's balanced from this
node bounced from here and balanced from
here and now we want to go back up to
the root node and make sure it's
balanced from here before we do that we
have to solve the sub problem on this
left subtree it's just a base case
problem right it's just a single node so
we know it's balanced from here as well
so now we want to go back up to the root
node is it balanced from this root node
well as we are doing this right as we
were doing this right subtree we
determined the height of this tree was
one the height of this tree was also one
right so now we want to know before from
from this node over here before we
return back up to the parent we want to
know what's the entire height of this
subtree how can we easily determine that
well we know that this was one this was
also one so from here the height is just
gonna be one meaning one this one comes
from this node over here plus the max of
its left and right subtrees which we
know are both one so we can take the max
of one and one that's going to end up
being one so the height of the overall
tree is just gonna be one plus one which
is two right so the height of this tree
is going to be 2. we determine that
pretty easily and that's what we can
return back up to this parent node which
is good for us right and from this tree
on the left the height is 1 because it's
just a single node so we return that up
to the parent as well so now from here
we know that the height of the left sub
tree is one the height of the right
subtree is two we can take that
difference two minus one it's one which
is less than or equal to uh one so that
we do know that this is balanced from
this
node as well right and we can continue
to recursively do that if we had another
parent node up above us somewhere we
could return okay the height of this
overall tree is going to be three right
so that's the main logic we're gonna
follow yes we're going to do this
recursively and there's many ways to
code this up the main way i'm going to
code this up is actually by returning
two values i'm going to return a boolean
as the first value which will be either
true or false basically for every single
subtree remember we are going to
determine is that subtree balance we'll
return a true or false for that and the
second value will be the height of that
subtree so from this subtree what we
would return is true because it is
balanced and the height we would return
is 2 right the height of the subtree is
2 so this is kind of what we would
return now if we ever from any single
subtree if we ever return false that
means we found at least one subtree
that's not balanced if we find even one
subtree that's not balanced that means
from the root we're going to end up
having to return false which i'll show
you how we can implement that in the
code it's pretty straightforward okay so
now let's get into the code and
main thing is we're going to do this
recursively why can't i just use this
outer function to do it because this
outer function just returns a single
value right the boolean but we actually
want to implement this by returning two
values so i'm gonna write a nested
recursive function here and we're gonna
pass in a single parameter which is the
root and remember this function is going
to return a pair of values a boolean and
the height of the tree so first things
first the base case if the root is a
null right this means that we have an
empty tree so is an empty tree
considered balanced yeah let's say it is
so for the first value we'll return true
in this case and the second value which
is the height of the tree an empty tree
we can assume just has a height of zero
let's say and now remember before we
determine from this root node is this
tree balanced first we want to determine
if from the left sub tree it is balanced
and from the right subtree is a balance
so let's call dfs recursively on the
right and left subtrees and then assign
it to the result variables left and
right so that's what we're doing with
the single line of code calling dfs on
both subtrees so now we want to know
from the root node is it balanced right
how can we determine that well we're
gonna have to take the absolute value of
the left and right heights right so how
can we do that we can take absolute
value left of index one because remember
the second value is where the height
happens to be left of one minus right of
one so this will give us that so as long
as this is less than or equal to one we
can say that the tree is balanced right
not not so fast because remember if
either of these left or right subtrees
ever returned false in the first
parameter then we know for sure that the
entire tree is not balanced right so
before we say uh that this condition is
enough we're gonna add two more
conditions we're going to say okay as
long as this is true meaning that from
the root it's balanced and the left and
right sub trees were also balanced so we
can determine that by just taking the uh
first the zero index of left and the
zero index of right
and also this condition over here let me
just reformat it slightly to make it a
little bit more readable this balance is
what we're going to be returning as the
first
as the zeroth index let me just show you
that so we're going to return a pair of
values the first is going to be is this
tree balanced and the second is going to
be the height of the tree how do we
determine the height of the tree well
it's going to be one
one comes from the root node that we're
currently at plus the max of the left
and right subtree so we can get that
pretty easily left at index one
and right at index one so whatever the
max of those two is plus one gives us
the height hopefully this is pretty
simple but the balanced might not be
this balance doesn't only mean is the is
the tree balanced from the root position
this balanced means is the entire tree
balanced at all because remember if the
left subtree for example was not
balanced then this conditional is going
to evaluate to false right because this
balance is only going to be true if the
left sub tree was balanced and the right
sub tree was balanced and from the root
subtree are we balanced right so all
three of those have to be true for us to
return true as the balanced variable
hopefully that makes sense because that
is the entire code once we're done with
that we can in the outer function we can
go ahead and call our dfs starting from
the root node and remember this dfs is
going to return two variable or a pair
of values right a boolean and the height
so which of those do we want to return
in the outer function we want to return
the boolean so we can return this at
index 0 and then that will be the entire
code so let me submit it to make sure
that it works as you can see on the left
it does work and it's pretty efficient
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports channel a lot and i'll
hopefully see you pretty soon thanks for
watching